I want to play a quick game with you if
you can yeah it's just a fun little game
we're calling top of that okay so we
kind of want to see who can have the
best most extreme answer if you guys can
top each other scenarios okay most
romantic thing you've ever done oh god I
mean the clock is ticking yeah I was
engaged at one point so I think that was
probably more romantic than anything
you've ever done yeah yeah you know me
pot you did that is that is pretty
romantic what about the biggest so fail
you've ever had in a relationship like a
time did you just like forget you up for
dinner oh there's plenty of other thing
rights related so I ever fail that goes
with that goes with not being romantic
we're in San Francisco we're at a thrift
store and I come across the shirt that
said number one grandma or something
like that and it had a sonogram of this
baby on it so i guess it was like some
grandma that had her grandchild sonogram
printed on a shirt and I thought it was
really funny and valentine's day was
coming around the corner so um I gave
that shirt to my girlfriend at the time
as a Valentine's Day gift turns out
that's not funny she warned and that's
look she actually this is actually the
funny thing she wore because it was a
big shirt so she wore it as like as like
a like a you know like a slip yeah damn
it yeah sleepwear yeah yeah so she
probably wore that shirt more than like
any other shirt she had no I mean I
can't top that no that's what is the
worst thing I ever did yeah what about
most expensive thing you've ever bought
who wins on that realm I don't know I
mean I would say a house but it's so
weird because when people say they
bought a house they're not actually
buying the house there they're like
getting a mortgage and Roy stuff I'd
stay my car then we're pretty practical
so yeah it would be true yeah me forgot
about that one I guess yeah yeah be car
cuz I get you right about the more you
say that about a house but I mean you're
not just like throwing all the money on
the table